Mick Baron
I'm 65 as of a month ago.
I've now got two little grandchildren.
And what really, you know, doesn't upset me but disturbs me is I cannot, now, I
will not be able to show them what I saw.
It's as simple as that.
Going back 30 years ago, if I wanted a crayfish, okay, you get a licence and go
and catch your three, four, five crays within a dive.
Can't do that anymore.
I can't do that here.
Nowhere.
So
the effect on my psyche is, yeah, it's very, very sort of distressing.
It disturbs me because the quality of the ocean has definitely changed.
There's no doubt about that.
And this is only in my lifetime, you know, I mean, if what's happening around
elsewhere continues to go, I don't know what's going to happen.
I really don't.
If the, if the climate change continues to affect this area to the same level within
the next generation.
Puh. Who knows.
To get the environment to manage itself,
you've got to give it a break.